Stewart went to China and Tibet to
research books about dong Xiao ping and
the Dalai Lama a couple of months ago
she spoke to great school students in
Metairie Louisiana this event is about
an hour
who started writing at a very early age
mrs. Whitney Stewart started writing
before she was even younger than you
were and in in her writing she learned
about other writers and how they wrote
and in her adventures she's done a lot
of traveling she's learned a lot about
many different people so part of her
writing has been about biographies and
she's going to share with us her
experiences and her travels to China and
Tibet so please give your attention and
please welcome miss Whitney Stewart is
that correct so you know where Tibet is
you know where China is worst event well
nobody's gonna tell me okay the reason
why I asked you so most people say in
China and in fact on maps these days yes
Tibet is in China but Tibetan for
Tibetans
they don't feel that their country is
part of China but the Chinese do so what
we're going to talk about today is the
relationship between Tibet and China and
I have written these two biographies I
think maybe some of you have visited the
website and seen them maybe you've been
able to click on the covers of these and
learned a little bit about the 14th
Dalai Lama and dong Xiao ping but I'm
going to tell you a little bit about
their stories I had been able to travel
to both countries and I've been able to
interview them unfortunately Doug
shopping had died before I decided to
write his book he died in 1997 so I
wasn't able to interview him furthermore
it's very difficult in fact to interview
Chinese leaders the Chinese government
doesn't doesn't allow their leaders to
have public access the way many other
countries do where journalists can go
and interview President Bush for example
it's very difficult to get an interview
with the Chinese leader even to meet
their family members I was unable to
actually get close to
young shopping as a subject so this book
was much harder for me to write the
Dalai Lama the 14th Dalai Lama I've
actually interviewed him 44 different
times so the slides I'm going to show
you I was able to get these old
photographs from a member of the Dalai
Lama's family I don't have old slides
that have to do with Deng Xiaoping so
before I start the slideshow I'm going
to talk about both of these figures I
actually wrote looking at both of these
characters I decided to for you this is
the first time I've actually given this
presentation for you I thought I'm going
to talk about these two side-by-side and
given a comparison of these two and then
I'm going to show you slides of old
Tibet and I'll tell you the story of the
14th Dalai Lama but I will weave in some
of the some of the stories of young Xiao
Peng these two actually had a lot to do
with each other they knew each other and
so I will tell you the story of dung
shopping within the story of the 14th
Dalai Lama this book also came out in
paper books so some of you may have seen
this cover it is actually the same book
as this one just has a different cover
on it so what I thought I would do was
compare these two I find that I have to
be interested in my subjects because I
live with them for about a year to two
so I have to really sometimes even
longer I have to like this person or at
least find him fascinating or her
because I'm going to be reading
everything I can on this person I'm
going to be interviewing this person I'm
going to be digesting the the interviews
and writing them down and analyzing them
I have to at least be fascinated or
curious about this subject and I knew I
was of the 14th Dalai Lama because I
went to his I went to bed I was a
mountain climber I climbed in Tibet I
climbed in Nepal I went to India where
he lives in exile do you know what exile
means it's a term yes you know
you can't return to the country that's
right he's an exile because he had to
leave his country when China invaded it
and he left in 1959 so he lives in India
and I went to India to live with the
Tibetan family and to interview the
Dalai Lama there but so I knew I was
interested in him and then my publisher
I decided I wanted to tell some stories
of China and my publisher said what
about thumb shopping and I thought to
myself I really didn't know that much
about dumb shopping except I didn't know
that dumb shopping was the man who
ordered the invasion of Tibet so I
thought well it would be very good for
me as a biographer to be objective and
to learn the other side of the story
this Chinese side of the Tibetan story
and that's why I wrote the book about
dumb shopping but now in looking at
these two subjects the other night when
I was writing this for you I thought
well there's actually a fascinating
comparison so I was contrasting and
comparing these two Dunc shopping was
born 31 years before the Dalai Lama
but in China at the time China was a
monarchy I mean it was a it was an
empire so the emperor was all-powerful
and those in that in the in the in the
imperial palace were all powerful but
there are many poor peasants in China
well at the same time this is at the
turn of the century okay so we're gonna
tell you the story really from about
1900 until about 1997 for dong shopping
when he died in Tibet at the same time
Tibet was run by the Dalai Lama who was
a monk and the monasteries had all the
power in Tibet and there were poor
peasants
so actually they were very similar but
at that time China was run by the
Manchus the Manchus were Buddhist people
and they had a relationship with Tibet
that goes way back to the Mongol period
of China
the Manchus because they were Buddhists
the the Empress Dowager she was the last
ruling Empress if you can see way over
there but you can come up afterward and
look at this book she was the last
ruling Empress Dowager of China she died
in 1908
she was Buddhist and she knew the 13th
Dalai Lama not the current Dalai Lama
but his predecessor
and in 1908 at the time she was having a
birthday she invited the 13th Dalai Lama
to come from Tibet to Beijing which is
quite a distance actually at that time
to come to Beijing to do Buddhist rites
and rituals for her birthday party not
long after that she started to die and
when Buddhists die they want monks
around them to save special rituals and
prayers so that their reincarnation
their deepest level of consciousness
will be reborn in a new body and they of
course most people want to have a better
rebirth not be reborn as an insect or
reborn reborn in a ghostly realm where
they actually don't come into a body
this is what Buddhists believe and so
she wanted to be reborn for a better
birth so she wanted the 13th Dalai Lama
to be her spiritual guide through death
so she wanted him at his site so that
you can see that the Chinese top Chinese
leaders on the top Tibetan had a very
close relationship at that time but
after she died then the young Emperor
Puyi I don't know if you've ever seen
the movie The Last Emperor that's a
fascinating movie maybe you can see it
you have to ask your parents The Last
Emperor was on the throne until 1912 and
at that time the people of China said we
don't want to be ruled by Emperor's
anymore we no longer believe that the
emperor is God we want they wanted not
necessarily democracy but they wanted a
People's Government and nationalist
party started getting stronger and
stronger and a man Yin named Sun yat-sen
started getting stronger and trying to
bring the people in and so they deposed
they actually took the Emperor off his
seat off his throne and the country was
it's a very huge country so you're
trying to imagine mobilizing people from
all over of China to have one
governmental system there were warlords
fighting each other all over China
so China was in chaos at the time when
dong shopping was born in 1904 shortly
before the Empress Dowager died
Tibet was not quite as chaotic but it
had poor suffering people ruled by
monasteries and the monks ran the
country and the peasants farmed the land
and gave the grain to the monastery
people in that country were 98 percent
of them were Buddhist so they were
pretty much following the system of
Buddhism run by the monks so there was
not so much chaos at that time although
they did want to change that system it
wasn't as chaotic whereas in China they
no longer wanted to be ruled by this
emperor who in times past was the
equivalent of a god they no longer
wanted to be ruled this way and so that
was it was chaotic so dumb shopping was
born into this lifetime and he was
raised he was born into a farming family
in a remote farming village in Sichuan
province not very far actually from the
capital of Tibet the Dalai Lama 31 years
later was also born into a remote
farming family and so their backgrounds
are very similar even their houses are
similar I was looking at my list of
comparing them thinking dunk shopping
was born in 1904 August 22nd thinking he
was born and his name that was given to
him was called first
sage the Dalai Lama was born his name
was la mode poem Duke when he was first
born and his name was wish-fulfilling
goddess so you couldn't see parents gave
the names of their children these sort
of religious spiritual names of hoping
their children would go and either be
very wise or very compassionate and dong
Xiao ping
he lived in a half-timbered house so
with big wooden beams but with earth
earth mud floors Dalai Lama was built
was born into a stone and mud house they
weren't exactly peasants they were a
little bit higher up in their society
than peasants they had strong families
of dung shopping he had seven siblings
and the Dalai Lama had six siblings Tong
shoppings family they grew rice wheat
corn and sorghum and the Dalai Lama his
family grew barley and buckwheat and
potatoes so you see just their
backgrounds already started off to be
very very similar Valley LAN was
father was known for his temper he was
definitely the leader of the household
he loved horses he had a quick temper
he's a strong personality dung shoppings
father 31 years earlier also had a
strong personality he was a political
leader he was very spiritual and he
wanted the best for his son and he cared
a lot about politics and about his
country China he sent his son to he also
had several wives so he had he had
children by different wives but of this
particular wife dong shopping was the
first son
so the first son in Chinese families a
lot of responsibility all the hopes of
the family to carry on and to be
successful same thing for the Tibetans
so he sent his son to France when he was
15 years old so it was it was strange
for this child who had been born in a
rural farming village to go by himself
actually he had an uncle who was not
much older go with him with some other
Chinese students China all all young
boys and men young men but it's still
the growing up in a rural farming
village and then go all the way to
France land in Paris this was strange
for dung shopping and he was quite
nervous and scared about it in the
beginning because it was a big
responsibility to carry his family and
to go all the way to France to be
educated by 15 years old the Dalai Lama
later on you'll see 15 years old he was
made political and spiritual leader of
his country so here both boys at age 15
had take on immense amount of
responsibility you all aren't quite 15
but can you imagine just in a couple
more years leaving a country or leaving
your family and going off to China to
study when you're 15 think about that a
little bit it's just I think it was even
more daunting back then when traveling
and internet and all of these things
didn't exist traveling didn't exist the
way it exists now it took dong shopping
quite a long time to get to Paris when
dong Frank ping got to France he was
supposed to be in a work-study program
so that he would learn
Newell skills mechanical skills business
skills and he would also study well the
people who are running that program were
corrupt they just wanted to take the
money and they offered very little in
fact to these young students the young
students ended up in France without much
money of their own some of them if they
were wealthy dung shopping was not
particularly wealthy some of them if
they were wealthy could at least live on
their own but they got there and
sometimes they couldn't they didn't even
have a school to go to or a job they
were stuck and they didn't have the
money to get back because the school the
the school program actually went
bankrupt while they were there dung
shopping was stuck and finally got
himself a job and he started working in
a factory in a tire factory at first had
several different jobs but he learned
manual labour and he also realized that
people who had these kind of jobs and
factories had terrible conditions they
were made to work 12 and 14 hours very
very little pay they lived in
dormitories connected to the
manufacturers and with very dismal
circumstances I think they didn't have
much heating they didn't have much food
so he had a very rough time in France
and suddenly he was exposed to communist
in France who were trying to bring
better conditions to workers in France
so suddenly the dung shopping was in a
foreign country without much money very
little to live on having to work in a in
a factory with very few skills he did
not speak French very well he was not a
great student he did okay but his grades
weren't stellar and French was very hard
for him so he didn't even have good
skills in French so what was he to do
without any money he couldn't even get
back home so he kept working from job to
job and he finally moves into Paris he
had gone to different regions of France
he moves into Paris and he needs young
communists who are all trying to bring
better conditions to French workers and
to foreign workers foreign workers were
treated even worse than the French
workers so he all of a sudden he's
exposed to communist thought the same
time the Dalai Lama and I'll get to
telling you his story in detail the
Dalai Lama was brought into a system
and he was discovered as the 14th Dalai
Lama and taken to be a young ruler when
he was a little child and he was brought
into a monastery he had no control over
his life brought into a monastery and he
became a tibetan buddhist monk learning
buddhist philosophy from a very early
age both of them really didn't have much
control at that stage of their lives but
they were in different different
circumstance one was seeing the world
the other was enclosed in palaces seeing
nothing but learning tibetan buddhist
scripture so they grew up in very
different systems dong shopping decided
he wanted to dedicate his life to
communist thought because he thought
that maybe communism was going to be the
answer to solve all of China's problems
so he went off he actually had to escape
France because at that time communism
was against the law in France and so the
French government was actually looking
for communists and trying to arrest them
so he had to escape he escaped in
through Germany first and then went from
Germany to Russia and in Russia at that
time Russia had a communist government
and the thought of Karl Marx his thought
was called Marxism was the base of
communist theory at that time and so
dumb shopping actually went to
university he hadn't had much schooling
but the Communists in Russia were
actually taking people who were very
interested in communism even if they
didn't have a you know their graduate
their high school degree or college
degree took them and they formed a
special college for communists in Russia
to train young Communist politicians and
dong shopping went to one of those
schools and he decided that communism
was going to be the way for China the
only way to help all of these poor
people throughout China
who's to have a communist government and
to be able to that there was no longer a
rich class and a poor class that they
would have what's called a classless
society that everyone would be equal
they would take money from the rich and
give it to the poor and make everyone be
equal and this is what dong Xiao ping
said he said I made up my mind to give
my whole life to our party and our class
more resolutely resolutely I am ready to
receive the party's training obey the
party's command
always fight for the interests of the
poll Italian poet Harriet means the
working-class so basically his goal was
to take the working-class people and
raise up their level of living in fact
sometimes even higher really then the
rich had been is this brought chaos to
China because the way people went about
doing this was not just okay everybody
you rich give to the poor and we'll all
be happy that's not what happened of
course those who had money and power did
not want to give it up not easily so
there was lots of war going on battles
and fights and the Communists moved in
took a very long time for them to
actually win over other parties that
were trying to take control and it was a
bloody affair and you can read more
about it in the biography because I
don't have time to tell all the details
but there are fascinating details but
the point of this my story is that thumb
shopping believed in this system and he
wanted to help and save his country and
he dedicated himself to the system of
communism at the same time the Dalai
Lama said he wanted to save the poor
people in his country but he was brought
up in a system of Buddhism
and everything about Buddhism is to not
harm anyone to teach with
loving-kindness and compassion so he
became dedicated to his system and this
is a quote from him as a Buddhist monk
my concern extends to all members of the
human family and indeed to all sentient
beings that means all-knowing beings so
he went about dedicating and he wanted
to change Tibet and modernize Tibet and
bring up the level of standard of living
for the poor people in Tibet but he
wanted to do it through Buddhism so they
had actually very similar motivation but
the way things went they went about and
then the way things happen in their
country were so different and you will
see that more I just wanted to make
another comparison and the year that
dunk shopping was also the man do you
know I don't know if you know about
chandaman Square but later on in the
1980s China wanted to move to a
democracy and young students were
calling for democracy
and they were in this main square in
Beijing called [ __ ] square calling
for democracy and at that very time dong
Xiao ping didn't does not instill up
until his time he died did not want his
country to move to a democracy still
felt that communism was the best for
China and so was what these democratics
these students for democracy were doing
was against the law he wanted to arrest
them he asked them all to lead this was
in 1989 maybe you have heard about this
but it's worth learning about dong Xiao
Peng was the one who ordered tanks to
come into Jamaat gentlemen Square and
fire upon these students who were had a
non-violent demonstration for democracy
but for dumb shopping and for China and
for those people who were leading the
country that was a very heroic move on
the part of dong Xiao ping that he was
willing to basically to just run over
these students and many died for the
sake of keeping communism in China
because he still felt that was the best
system and he was applauded by many for
killing these young democracy students
at the same year the Dalai Lama
won the Nobel Peace Prize for his
nonviolent call for negotiation with
China to get his country back it's very
interesting the exact same year that
dong shopping does something for his
country that's so violent the Dalai Lama
wins for his country the Nobel Peace
Prize
so it's interesting so when you went if
you have a chance to look at these books
you might want to think about these two
that they both were born in two very
different systems and thought what they
were doing was right within the system
in which they were raised so now I'm
going to tell you the story about the
dalai lama which is fascinating it's
almost more bizarre than a fairy tale
that we're used to if someone could
please turn on the slide projector and
i'll tell you in fact how the dalai lama
and dung shopping met one another
okay now did anyone note the music when
you came in that work those were Tibetan
Buddhist monks chanting this is gonna
hit you a little bit I'm sorry if you
want to move over you fear be more
comfortable to slide a little bit okay
sorry
those were Tibetan Buddhist monks
chanting and playing the horns as you
see here this is part of their ritual
they are met the form of meditation
actually they are calling the divine
with what they call deities now to
bettan Buddhists can you all see this if
you can't come up afterward okay Tibetan
Buddhists have these image these images
which they call deities if they do not
consider them gods the way Christians
think of God there is no one Creator God
in Buddhism these are actually states of
mind so if you want to generate
compassion and loving-kindness within
yourself you would meditate on this
particular form for example this this
form is called Chenrezig in Tibetan and
the Tibetans believe that the dalai lama
is in fact an incarnation of this deity
in other words they believe that he's
the embodiment the human being that
embodies loving-kindness and compassion
so if you were to wash your tibetan monk
or nun and you wanted to generate
compassion within yourself as lewis do
for all beings you would look sit in
front of this image in meditation you
sit in meditation form with your legs
crossed sitting up straight and you had
meditate on that form that it actually
melt would melt inside of you so that
you became that form
you became compassion and that's what
Tibetan Buddhists do and this monk he is
in a ritual ceremony blowing a horn to
call this deity to the monks so that he
could become compassion let's see make
sure I'm going forward here
this is a flag of Tibet with the potala
palace this is the dalai lama's palace
where he was raised and has over a
thousand rooms it used to have a dungeon
a prison underneath it was first built
by the fifth Dalai Lama
in the 1600s the fifth Dalai Lama was a
very strong leader and he had a
relationship with the Mongols who at
that time were in China and the Tibetans
were the spiritual leaders for the
Chinese for the Mongols
and the Mongols were the political they
were the army that would protect Tibet
they liked each other a lot and that's
why nowadays the Chinese say seat that
has always been part of China all the
way back to the Mongol period where the
Chinese say yes we had a relationship
with the Mongols and then later on we
had a relationship with the Manchus and
I showed you that Empress Dowager who
was Buddhist but when she died and the
Empire stopped later on the Dalai Lama
13th Dalai Lama said ok we are no longer
part have a relationship with China the
Han Chinese people are not Buddhist they
have a very different culture and
language than we do and we now are going
to be our own country with our own
currency our own passport our own system
of government and we were living next to
China they closed off the barrier
between the two countries every well the
Chinese who are in Tibet there weren't
very many or sent back to China and
Tibet at that point declared its
independence the Chinese do not see
history the same way they felt as if
they still had this relationship so the
5th Dalai Lama anyway he was building
this way back when he still had a
relationship with the Mongols he died
and the potala palace wasn't finished
but he wanted donations from the people
to so they can continue building this
his monks who were living after him
wanted more money so they continued
building this great palace for the Dalai
Lama so the monks didn't tell the people
that the Dalai Lama had died they said
he'd gone into silent retreat for 15
years that people kept pouring in
donations until this was finally built
and then they were told that the leader
had just died not very truthful was it
now this is the visions of Tibet you see
this region called hood song this is
where the capital city Lhasa is that
area now is what's called Tibetan
Autonomous Region if you were to look at
a map it would be the Tibetan region of
China whereas if you see all the rest of
this um though all of that now has been
absorbed into the into China you don't
see it it marked like that on a map but
that's what the Tibetans believe is
still their country and the Dalai Lama
comes from that region and the Northeast
called um no the 13th Dalai Lama died in
1933 in his palace there he is
he died in 1933 now when he died all
that monks around him said we need to
find the reincarnation because he was
not only political lead in spiritual
leader but he was political leader of
the country as well so they needed a new
political leader they didn't have
elections in the country what they did
is they found the reincarnation of the
Dalai Lama and then enthroned him and
until just like you know Kings in Old
England and while he was young they
would have the country run by a regent
somebody who had political power just
until the Dalai Lama was old enough to
run his own country when he died he was
put on a tomb and on the northeast
column of that tomb was a strange
star-shaped fungus was growing and so
the Tibetan monks around and we're
looking for signs where are we gonna
find him in all of Tibet where are we
gonna find his reincarnation and so they
thought mmm
northeast column we see the strange
fungus growing on his - maybe that's
significant they also saw strange cloud
formations in the northeast corner of
the sky
so they were very mystical these monks
and they believe in signs and then one
of the high Lamas in their system a lama
means a teacher in Tibetan Buddhism one
of the lamas went to to meditate by a
sacred lake and it was believed that
Buddhist believe that in the waters of
that lake you could a high monk could
actually get a vision so the monks one
monk meditated in front of his lake and
he
a vision of a monastery with a turquoise
roof and he saw a house with a strange
system of gutters made out of branches
on the roof and he saw the three tibetan
letters and you can see how they're
written in one of my books
ah kha ma in tibetan writing he didn't
really know the significance of that but
he felt it might be important so he
wrote down these things and then he gave
them to a group of monks and said these
are some signs maybe they'll be useful
the monks felt okay we should travel to
the northeast corner of Tibet we think
that's significant there are some boys
in that part of Tibet in undoh region
who have been thought to perhaps have
some special qualities we'll go and
interview them and so they did but there
were no roads this is the Potala Palace
these are worshippers I actually took
this picture myself in 1986 but I just
wanted to show you a close-up of the
dalai lama's palace where he would come
to live now these were the monks these
were the government leaders who are in
Tibet at the time when all these
decisions were being made I wanted to
show you what old Tibet looked like the
way the country was run but as I told
you like China was run by the Emperor
Tibet was run by the monks and if you
look at their dress and the pageantry
it's very similar the world silken robes
these were Tibetan government officials
at the time were making the decisions as
to where to go to find the 14th Dalai
Lama this was a noble family and I
showed this picture actually because
when the Lama dong-gook or the 14th
Dalai Lama was first discovered his
family as I said was a farming family
but because their child was the
incarnation of the Dalai Lama they were
raised in society to be a noble family
so suddenly from the farming family they
became like this family a noble family
and this family was posed for a
photograph and they're showing their
wealth you can see the woman the mother
of the family was wearing all of her
jewelry and the apron she's wearing is
to signify that she's married and the
long sleeves of her dress which is
called a tsuba signify that she doesn't
have to do any manual labor they come
longer than her fingers and she's
standing up
means she doesn't have to do anything
with her hands so she's a noblewoman
here's another noble woman she's rolled
up her sleeves a little bit but she too
doesn't have to do very much labor she
has servants who work for her and you
can see their fancy headdress this is
also a way of showing wealth and on the
other hand these two children of course
are not from a noble family and I just
wanted to give you the contrast this is
the way most Tibetans lived and they
also are wearing their tubas but they're
worn of tattered cloth and children had
to work in that time because there was
no system of Education but there was no
public education the only people who
were educated were monks not even nuns
in those days now there are nuns but at
that time usually one or two boys from
every family would go to a monastery and
become a monk and that was the only way
they were to get educated
now the 13th Dalai Lama was trying to
change all that he too wanted to
modernize the country but the
government's officials around him didn't
like the changes he was making but he
tried to send out some Tibetans
to England to get education but he just
started it slowly this is what Tibet
looked like in the 1980s but it's this
housing is just very similar to what
they had early on when the Dalai Lama
was 14,000 I was born in 1935 you can
see these houses made of mud dried in
the Sun again some courtyards in old
Tibet now the the Tibetan monks when
they wanted to go find the 14th Dalai
Lama there were no roads in Tibet and
there was only one car and that car had
been taken apart carried over the
Himalayan mountains from India and then
reassembled but nobody to drive it
because nobody had driver's license they
didn't have fuel so they had a car but
there were no roads to drive on anyway
so they traveled by yak yak is a high
altitude animal similar to a bison
doesn't even like to come down below
about 10,000 feet it actually doesn't do
well at low altitude
I had to travel for several months
across high mountain pass over 20,000
feet high and it was very cold for about
two months traveling this way and they
subsisted on butter tea Tibetans drink
tea that's brewed with salt and butter
lots of butter and it's kind of like a
broth and they eat barley meal ground-up
dried in a powder and sometimes they mix
their butter tea and butter into their
barley meal a little bit like hot cereal
and they lived on that as they traveled
across the country not much can grow in
Tibet particularly in some regions
because it's so dry and at a high
altitude and rocky so they live on
barley which is quite a hearty grain and
they went across mountain paths like
these to get to UM dough now in um dough
the lead monk his name was Keith saw
grandpa shake heat song rinpoche
Rinpoche means reincarnated Lama
so Rinpoche has a high title and is
usually treated very well by servants
and you know people come to see him they
honor him
Keith saw grandpa Shay disguised himself
as the servant monk and the servant monk
disguised himself as the head Lama the
head teacher the head monk and I guess
there are a couple of other monks as
well Keith's a grandpa she did this
because he was knocking on the doors of
the houses where these young boys had
been discovered who might have sort of
special qualities and he came to la mode
on loops house and la madone doop was
there with his mother in the kitchen and
his mother came to the door at that time
in Tibet there weren't hotels so people
were quite it was quite customary for
people to open the door to travelers and
invite them in for tea or to spend the
night so today I Lamas Runner mother who
was very kind and compassionate
immediately opened the door to these
monks and said please come in and your
servant monks can come and use my
kitchen and prepare whatever you need so
Keith song Rinpoche disguised as a
servant monk came into the kitchen
because he wanted to see the little boy
of the household and have free reign and
not be sitting in the other room you
know in a chair in a place of honor and
he saw a mogul Duke and Keith sovereign
Boucher was wearing
malas and malas are very similar to a
rosary Tibetan Buddhists count their
mantras or their sacred words on these
malas and so all Tibetan Buddhist monks
wear them and keeps I appreciate was
wearing a mala and the little Bell is on
the little little Lama go who went
running up to him and said those are
loving give him to me those are mine
he was about to now I'm Keats on what
she said yes yes yes yes you can have
them if you tell me who I am and the
little boy said Sarah llama llama means
teacher or monk monk teacher Sarah means
sera monastery in the capital city of
Lhasa now how this little boy who had
never been out of his home territory in
Armco knew this nobody knows but he knew
who this monk was nobody had told him
according to the stories and he also
could identify the other monks in the
group so of course all the monks thought
hmm he knows who we are
so they got suspicious they left and
when they left the Dali Lama Lama going
to crying crying terribly he wanted them
to stay or he wanted to go with them and
his mother said well it's very strange
he always says he wants to go to Lhasa
and he sits on the windowsill and he
pretends he's riding a horse that he
wants to go to Lhasa he always says this
so the monks are all getting very
suspicious maybe we found the right
child they come back a few days later
and with them they bring very various
ritual instruments this is a bell used
in Tibetan Buddhist ceremonies and adore
J this is a symbol of cutting through
ignorance used in Tibetan Buddhist
ceremonies and drum and a few other
things this is also used in Tibetan
Buddhist ceremonies and they lined up
all of these these artifacts and they
said to the little boy oh and they had
two of each one which had belonged to
the 13th Dalai Lama and one usually that
looked a little bit more attractive a
little bit more Bijou
or just colourful and they also had a
walking to walking sticks and they asked
a little boy to choose the ones that
were his and in each case he chose the
artifact that had belonged to the 13th
Dalai Lama so the monks felt he
recognized what used to be his in his
former life and then except when he came
to the walking sticks and when he came
to the walking sticks he hesitated on
one of them and then was gonna grab it
and then put it down and then took the
other one well later on it was
discovered that both of those walking
sticks had belonged to the 13th Dalai
Lama but that the incorrect one had been
given away by the 13th Dalai Lama to
somebody else
and maybe that was the cause of the
hesitation so the monks said we think we
have the candidate and then they did
some meditations there were other secret
things that they did that I don't even
know about Dalai Lama doesn't tell
people and they sent word back with a
runner a runner in Tibet on him yak back
to Lhasa to say we think we found the
right boy and so the people in Lossless
the government officials said bring him
here we think we found the right one but
there was a Chinese governor in that
region of Ando he was corrupt and he
said aha you found the famous Dalai Lama
in my territory you're not taking him
from here unless you give me money and
it was a very large sum of money but
they had to raise the money and pay this
man his bribe and just as soon as they
were ready to go
that same governor said well I want some
more money and they didn't have any more
money they had to borrow some money for
some Muslim traders who are in the
country at that time they borrowed some
money from that trading group and then
they finally were able to bring the
Dalai Lama and in thrown him like this
you can see as the 14th reincarnation of
the Dalai Lama the term Dalai Lama is
often translated as ocean of wisdom Lama
as I said means teacher and valet means
open but it's sort of wide expanse of
wisdom and it's a Mongolian term given
to the 3rd Dalai Lama by the Mongol
leader at that time so it's a very old
term
that has been carried on all the way to
the 14th Dalai Lama you can see here
that he is wearing a hat and this is a
symbol of wisdom this one was given to
me actually was given to my son by a
reincarnated Lama who came to stay with
us in New Orleans in fact we've had many
groups of Tibetan Buddhist monks who
have come to New Orleans and often they
state they stay with us and so I've just
given you an example this is a this is a
symbol of a hat worn or this example of
a hat worn by a Tibetan reincarnation of
a Tibetan Buddhist monk now the dalai
lama is the highest buddhist monk in the
country but there are other
reincarnation zuv high Lamas or teachers
who are venerated in the tibetan
buddhist system so there are many not
just one these were the dalai lamas
teachers now he was taken from his
family and he was very sad about that
because he was very close to his mother
and his mother and father were given a
house a beautiful house underneath the
at the foot of the Potala Palace but he
could only see his mother once a month
only his immediate older brother
lovesong something came to live with him
and so he had no other playmates but his
immediate older brother and these were
his two teachers who were very strict
particularly Ling Rinpoche the one on
the left when he was about five years
old he started his education he learned
how to write read and write Tibetan and
they have four different scripts in
Tibetan so he had a lot of learning to
do and he learned metaphysics and
philosophy from a very early age he was
a very reluctant student at first he was
smart but he was not interested in this
kind of learning he wanted his fruit
life of freedom and he was quite
mischievous and he is lost on something
would spend a lot of time going through
all of those thousand rooms in the
potala palace digging through the the
crates and boxes and chests of things
that had belonged to his predecessor the
13th dalai lama and there were all sorts
of things watches and cameras and
national Geographics and old films and
all sorts of things and he'd loved to
take things apart so he would take apart
and put back together watches and
cameras and even no one would instruct
him on
do this but he loved to do it he even
took apart this car engine and put it
back and got it in working order and he
he also built a movie studio and put
together a movie camera so he could take
movies of of the monks and people in
society and seeing some of those films
really really wonderful nobody wanted
him to be doing this the monks around
him were really just a you showed him a
lot of disdain for for this kind of
behavior because they thought he should
be just practicing his teachings and
meditating and and doing things that a
monk should do but he wanted to
modernize his country and he wanted to
learn about the world and he was very
curious and still is this was his summer
palace called norbulinka which is just a
few miles away from the Potala Palace
and he much preferred this palace in the
summertime he would that was the only
time he came out of the palaces was when
he was transferring from the potala
palace to the norbulinka palace and this
is the courtyard of the jokhang temple
which is in the center of Tibet in Lhasa
where he was to take his final degree
his final tests verbal tests it's like
defending a PhD thesis for a Geshe
degree and the Geshe is the highest
level highest degree for Tibetan
Buddhist monks in their monastic College
and you have to go against hundreds of
monks who ask you questions on what
you've been studying and they decide
whether or not you have passed together
gessie degree and it took place here now
in the Dalai Lama was born in 1935 at
age 15 there was in 1949 is when the
Communists took over
Mao Satan took over the government in
China they won against the Nationalists
in China and communism took hold of
China through a revolution that had been
quite chaotic by 1950 the Communists
said malchik Tung and dung shopping who
was one of the leaders at that time said
we want to move into Tibet Tibet is part
of China we need to expand there we need
to liberate the Tibetans
the poor Tibetan people from the rich
oppressors and from the foreign
influence another thing that was
happening in China was that foreign
countries were trying to trade and
influence the government in China the
Communists wanted end of all of this
foreign influence they also wanted that
for Tibet so they wanted to move into
Tibet and any kind of foreign influence
in Tibet and end the poverty of the
people in in Tibet or the peasants in
Tibet this did need to happen in Tibet
even the 13th and the 14th Dalai Lama
both wanted to change the system but
they didn't wanted to do it the same way
the Chinese did but 1950 dung shopping
was the military leader of the troops in
the region in Sichuan province closest
to Tibet so he was the one who actually
ordered the invasion and went with his
troops into Tibet and this was a very
violent invasion so the people of Tibet
said we want the Dalai Lama now to be
our leader even though he was only 15
and most dalai lamas didn't actually
take over full leadership until they
were 18 the Tibetans wanted him so
instead of these are monks studying
Buddhism and debating Buddhism with each
other they didn't want him to spend as
so much time debating his Buddhist
philosophy they wanted him to be
enthroned to save them from the Chinese
this is a photograph of the Panchen Lama
at that time he was the second highest
Lama in the country and I show this
picture because when the Chinese came in
on when the Dalai Lama later on in 1959
left Tibet he couldn't get out and he
was imprisoned by the Chinese and became
actually their puppet and they had him
under their control for a very long time
and so this is picniced as a picture
actually I have to back up a little bit
in time and then not explain the picture
so as the Chinese are invading in 1950
the Dalai Lama and the Panchen Lama want
to try to negotiate calmly with the
Chinese so they're constantly meeting
with government officials what do we do
do we escape
and go into India and set up a
government and then try to negotiate do
we come face to face with the Chinese
and the Dalai Lama said I think I need
to go to Beijing to talk to Mao Zedong
so in 1954 and I think I have a picture
I'm not sure if you'll be able to see it
but you can come up afterward some of
you will be able to see it there's a
picture I have here of the Panchen Lama
who's in my slide and the Dalai Lama
meeting Mao Zedong in Beijing in 1954 he
went all the way to the capital of China
to negotiate and to learn what Mao was
doing in China and the Dalai Lama was
actually very interested in colonies at
communism at first and said maybe this
system that has no hierarchy no upper
class and lower class maybe this is what
we need in in Tibet for the Tibetans
maybe but so the dialogue was actually
getting very interested in in communism
for a long time until he was there for a
year until Mao say to him one time took
him aside and said but religion is
poison
part of the communist system is having
no religion they are atheist and
Tibetans are devoutly Buddhists as I
said 98% of the Tibetans believe in the
Dalai Lama and our Buddhists so the
Dalai Lama thought how can that system
work in our country when so much part of
life is about worshipping and meditating
and believing in this Tibetan Buddhist
system so unfortunately that was at that
time that the ILOM I thought well I
don't think that what the Chinese are
offering us is going to help in Tibet
but he still wanted nonviolent
negotiation with the Chinese the Chinese
agreed and the Mao Zedong said okay fine
you sign these agreements excuse me with
us and that's what they're doing here
we will peacefully come into your
country and bring communism into your
country it will not be violent you will
still have control of your country
that's what was said but it's not what
happens the Chinese took over and four
nine four four let's see five more years
violently and
the country the Tibetans didn't really
have an army they tried to get together
any kind of weapons that they could
there were bloody battles many Tibetans
died the Chinese came and destroyed
monasteries in fact they had something
like thirteen thousand monasteries in
Tibet and there are only about 13 left
they destroyed them they tried to
destroy the religion they said religion
was poison and so unfortunately this
nonviolent negotiation turned into a
violent war by 1959 the Dalai Lama's
advisor said you got to get out you need
to we need to keep you safe go into
India India India is offering new
sanctuary go into India and the Tibetans
did not want the dilemma to leave
because he was their leader they
surrounded his palace he was in the
Summer Palace at that time they
surrounded this palace and they the
Chinese had invited the Dalai Lama to a
Chinese performance and died Lama said
well I'll come to this but the Tibetans
heard about this they surrounded his
palace they said he can't leave because
the Chinese had said but don't bring any
bodyguards the Dalai Lama doesn't go
anywhere without bodyguards
the Tibetans thought that they were
going to kill him Tibetans surrounded
the palace the Dalai Lama had to secret
he said I can't come to your performance
and later he disguised himself as a foot
soldier and I'm trying to speed up a
little bit to give you some time for
questions but just to the end of the
story he disguised himself and he had to
go over the mountains on horseback and
on foot and escaped
he crossed misses his family members and
all of his family went out with him he
had a power party of about a hundred he
came down to this river that was near
his palace and they snuck across it and
dark in a yak skin boat and then they
crossed mountain ranges and came to this
village came into India where Nehru was
running India at that time gave him
sanctuary gave him this land this
village is called Dharamsala it's about
12 hours north of New Delhi and he then
was able to start a government in exile
bring his government officials to Tibet
to India to Dharamsala and about 100
thousand Tibetans followed him out
because they worship him to such a
degree they wanted to be near him and
the dalai lama opened he and his mother
and his sister it's the pictures of him
when he came to india opened up this is
his mother and his sister they opened up
Tibetan schools Tibetan medical clinics
and housing for Tibetans who were
fleeing their country and that is where
I met him this is all pictures these are
pictures that I took in Dharamsala when
I lived there with a Tibetan family this
is the reincarnation of his senior tutor
the one I told you who was quite strict
sitting on the left-hand side this is
lingering p'chai his reincarnation was
found in India and now they're raising
him to be a Tibetan lama the
reincarnation in in northern India this
is the Dalai Lama giving a speech and a
press conference in 1989 because he had
never called for violent action against
China and he always spoke about peaceful
negotiations with China and treating the
whole world not just the Chinese but
treating everyone with peace in 1989 he
was given a Nobel Peace Prize just so
happens that the very day that his Nobel
Peace Prize was announced I'm a mother
and I were scheduled to interview him
for one of my books so it was a crazy
day this happened to be in California
one of my interviews with him was in
California when the whole world of
course wanted to interview the Nobel
Peace Prize winner and my mother and I
were there to talk about very different
subject for the Nobel Peace Prize and
all the journalists in the world were
waiting till we finished our interview
this is his um his private office in
India where I first waited to meet him
and this is a picture of him waving
that's the end of the slide and I think
I have just about ten minutes to ask to
answer questions if you all have any
either about dung shopping or about the
Dalai Lama oh I do want to say one thing
the Dalai Lama when dong Xiao ping died
I thought it was very interesting the
Dalai Lama made a statement as much as
you could see these two as enemies it is
not in the Dalai Lama's religion or
spirit to say
truly negative things about someone he
has to look for the best qualities in
someone and when the dung shopping died
he said I had known him personally when
I visited China in 1954 mr. dong
shopping was a man of few words he was a
revolutionary and a great leader of
China with an exceptional courage
perseverance capability and leadership
ability but and he goes on mr. Deng was
the leader of a communist party's
totalitarian system even if he
personally wanted to do good the system
itself dictated what to do so it is
inevitable that many mistakes were made
but I thought it was actually quite
generous of him you could have thought
this was his enemy but the Dalai Lama as
a Buddhist
as I said tries to look for the best
sides and did see that the dung shopping
had quite positive qualities as well
okay any questions yes oh sorry
can you wait to get the don't show ping
mean in Chinese Chung how ping it means
small and peaceful okay it also can mean
I'm told by a Chinese expert little
bottle or it can be twisted to mean to
play on words little bottle and when the
democracy leaders during Tiananmen
Square were against dong Xiao ping they
they put little bottles up around on
tables or something and then knock them
over as a symbol they wanted to knock
Tong shopping out of office I didn't
actually witness that but I heard about
it anybody else yes
back to their country the Dalai Lama and
his people ever able to move back to his
country no it is now 2002 and they left
in 1959 - not all Tibetans left there
are six million Tibetans who stayed in
the country more coming out every day
but there are about only about a hundred
and fifty thousand refugees who live in
India Nepal Canada Switzerland America
they live around the world but in those
places primarily and the others are
living under a communist Chinese system
which is quite sad I went to Tibet in
1986 and I went again in 1998 and one
thing that is very clear even if you're
untrained and noticing these things is
that Tibetan the the Communist Chinese
are really putting a damper on Tibetan
Buddhism because the economy the system
doesn't believe in religion they don't
allow the Tibetans to practice their
religion they have monasteries but
they're really tourist places so
tourists come and look at these places
and give money to go into them or
photograph them but there's really not
very much actual learning going on for
the monks and nuns
if monks if young people want to become
monks and nuns they try to escape to
that and come to India and there are
Tibetan settlements throughout India and
Nepal so there are two bettan
monasteries and nunneries in those
countries and even in America now there
are some some Tibetan monks and nuns
have moved to America and actually
because of that many Americans and
Europeans have now become Buddhist
because there are so many monks and nuns
coming to our countries that people are
become interested in Tibetan Buddhism
and in Western in the West
any other questions wait till the mic
comes over to you yes the turquoise roof
and the strange system of gutters and
the accommodation I forgot to tell you
that when the monks got to the unknow
region in its village called tucks a
tucks a monastery had a turquoise roof
lamode on Duke the dalai lama's house
had a system of gutters with strange
branches and a comma they don't know for
sure but they think might have been um
at the aah was a representative um
though and the comma perhaps come boom
monastery which is the monastery that
had the turquoise roof and you had a
question yeah right there being right
the Dali Lama I never could find a quote
by dumb chopping about the Dalai Lama I
found a quote of dung shopping saying
that the Tibetans all wanted the Chinese
to come and were very happy that the
Chinese were coming to liberate their
country which if you interview most
Tibetans that isn't the case but I don't
know whether dung shopping respected the
Dalai Lama
i I did know I wish I could find that I
looked very hard way back there both
glasses ping when he died 93 oh that was
another interesting thing glad you
brought that up
dunks one other contrast is that dunk
shopping wanted to stay in control in
power even though he was no longer the
premier of China at that late age he was
still holding the power sort of behind
this behind the scenes until he was
until his death whereas the Dalai Lama
last year decided he really wanted the
Tibetan government now to be a democracy
and he said I no longer wants to be
political leader I only want to be
spiritual leader and the Tibetans had
their very first election for a prime
minister last year and they've they've
slowly been moving towards democracy but
they finally but with the Dalai Lama as
head but last year they elected this
Prime Minister and now too religious
sorry too political administrators from
the guy lamas government are in America
and they are studying to learn to write
drafts and to write bills they're
learning from American government
officials how to do this and two of them
are going to be living with us for my
family for two weeks and going to Tulane
law school to learn how to wrap draft
write drafts I guess with people from
all over the world Tulane has a summer
program for this yes
and the Dalai Lama stay in that palace
that the fifth Dalai Lama um that's a
good question at the time when the Dalai
Lama was went living there women were
not allowed in the palace after dark but
they could come in during the day his
mother could also had to leave when it
got dark
it was pretty much run by monks but I
think there were some servants who were
not monks who are often there then
sometimes there are monks who don't
don't progress very high in the Tibetan
Buddhist system so they sort of stay
cooks and and whatnot but they're also
monks and they were part of living they
were living in there and being running
the household yes wait till the mic
comes to you with glasses yeah Oh was
how come only his brother could stay to
live with him why not his dad why not
his dad that's a good question I don't
know the answer to that one
his dad was not a monk perhaps that was
the reason his immediate older brother
was also considered a reincarnate Lama
but not of the same stature as the Dalai
Lama he actually had two older brothers
who were reincarnate Lamas and in fact
one of them moved to America and then he
was no longer a monk when he moved to
America he still lives here he raised
his family in America any questions on
this side of the room wait over here
why weren't women allowed in the palace
after dark women weren't allowed in the
palace after dark because Tibetan
Buddhist monks are celibate and they
don't marry and they didn't have
actually much contact with women in
their family yes but in general they
stayed fairly secluded from women women
would have been a distraction I think to
their to their meditations yes you have
a question there why was it Dalai Lama
exiled from his country he well he was
exiled because the Chinese took over and
the Tibetans were afraid that they
wanted to kill the Dalai Lama and the
Tibetans
you know honor him worship him and they
wanted to keep him safe so his advisor
said you must escape I think we have
time for just one more question
anybody yes right there summer palace oh
that's a good question you know I don't
know I've been to the Summer Palace a
couple of times but I've never counted
but it was much much smaller I think it
only had two floors and it was maybe
more of the size of not even as big as
the White House probably I think that's
as many questions because you all have
to go on to your next class but you've
been a really good audience and you had
very intelligent questions thank you
thank you miss Stewart so much for a
presentation we were all fascinated and
we really enjoyed you're sharing your
experiences with us
and should we show our appreciation for
him is Whitney's thing Whitney Stewart's
books on dung shopping and the Dalai
Lama are published by Lerner public